CALLED ME AND MADE SURE --
>> Tucker: THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
WIFE IN BROWARD COUNTY, FLORIDA
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
HORRIFYING SHOOTING.
SHORT TIME AGO WE SPOKE WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE PRINCIPAL DEPUTY
SECRETARY.
ROD SHAW JOINS US FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
RAJ THESE INDICTMENTS SAY THAT
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE BEGAN IN
2014.
DO YOU SEE THE 13 INDICTMENTS AS
VINDICATION FOR YOU?
>> WE ABSOLUTELY DO.
REALLY, THERE'S THREE MAIN
POINTS THAT WE SEE FROM THESE
INDICTMENTS.
ONE AS YOU MENTION THEY STARTED
THIS PLOT STARTED IN 2014 BEFORE
THE PRESIDENT JUMPED IN THE
RACE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE ALSO SAW IS
THAT THEY PROVED THERE'S NO
COLLUSION.
THE BIGGEST POINT THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN MAKING SINCE
BEFORE THIS INVESTIGATION BEGAN.
THE LAST POINT THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION, RATHER THE
INDICTMENTS MADE CLEAR IS THAT
ALL OF THESE EFFORTS WERE ABOUT
SEWING CONFUSION IN THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS AND
UNDERMINING THE NEXT.
.
NOT ABOUT SUPPORTING ONE
CANDIDATE OVER THE OTHER.
SO, REALLY, WHEN YOU SEE THESE
EFFORTS BY DEMOCRATS THAT PUSH
THIS COLLUSION CONSPIRACY, WHAT
THEY ARE DOING IS DOING THE
DIRTY WORK FOR THE RUSSIANS FOR
THEM, THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS, MAKING FALSE CLAIMS,
THAT REALLY PUSH WHAT THE
RUSSIANS WANT THEM TO PUSH.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT'S YOU
TRUE.
ALSO PARADOXICALLY, ROBERT
MUELLER, WHO HAS BEEN SEEN AS AN
ENEMY OF THE WHITE HOUSE, IS
HELPING THE WHITE HOUSE' CASE
TONIGHT.
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN COOPERATIVE
WITH THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID
THAT IT'S A HOAX, THAT THE
CHARGE OF COLLUSION IS FALSE, HE
WOULD BE THE ONE TO KNOW.
WE'VE SOMETIME BEEN COOPERATIVE,
WE STILL PROVIDED WITH ITS,
DOCUMENTS, ET CETERA.
AND NOW IT'S HELPED UNCOVER THIS
ELABORATE PLOT WITHIN MANY
RUSSIAN INDIVIDUALS THAT HAD NO
COOPERATION, ACTIVE COOPERATION
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND IT REALLY SHOWS THAT WHAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE ALLEGED, HAVE
CHARGED, AND FRANKLY MADE
OUTLANDISH CLAIMS ABOUT IS
TOTALLY BASELESS.
>> Tucker: IT ALSO SETS AN
INTERESTING PRECEDENT, AS YOU
WELL KNOW LIVING IN WASHINGTON
THERE'S A LOT OF FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE INTO OUR POLITICS.
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT FOR
EXAMPLE HAS RUN VOTER
REGISTRATION DRIVES AT AMERICAN
CONSULATES.
THAT SEEMS LIKE AN OBVIOUS
EFFORT TO INFLUENCE ELECTION
OUTCOMES.
DO YOU THINK THERE WILL BE
INDICTMENTS THERE?
>> I'M NOT A LAWYER AND WOULDN'T
PLEDGE TO KNOW WHAT STATUTES MAY
OR MAY NOT HAVE BEEN VIOLATED.
THE PLOT OF ACTIVE COLLUSION
BETWEEN A 20167 CAMPAIGN -- 2016
CAMPAIGN AND FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
WAS HILLARY CLINTON'S GOVERNMENT
OPERATING OUT OF THE UKRAINIAN
EMBASSY IN COLLUSION WITH THE
DNC AND TRYING TO DROP
OPPOSITION RESEARCH ON DONALD
TRUMP AND MEMBERS OF THE
PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE EXAMPLES OF
FOREIGN INFLUENCE IN CAMPAIGNS.
AND THERE IS AN EXAMPLE OF
COLLUSION IN THE LAST CAMPAIGN.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS.
AND HIS CAMPAIGN.
>> Tucker: WOULD YOU CONCEDE
THAT WE'RE SPENDING A LOT OF
TIME EXAMINING, AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S BAD, BUT RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE ON OUR COUNTRY,
SOCIETY, OUR POLITICS.
DO YOU THINK THIS WILL KICK OFF
A NEW ERA WHERE WE TAKE A CLOSE
LOOK AT THE INFLUENCE OF A LOT
OF OTHER COUNTRIES ON OUR
POLITICS.
IF NOT WHY NOT?
>> WELL, I THINK THE ISSUE OF
FOREIGN INFLUENCE IN AMERICAN
ELECTIONS IS A SERIOUS ONE.
IT'S A REAL ONE.
YOU KNOW, YOU JUST MENTIONED ONE
EXAMPLE.
I'M SURE THERE ARE MANY OTHERS.
OF COURSE, WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S ININTEGRITY IN OUR
ELECTION PROCESS, INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE VOTING ARE ALL
REGISTERED CITIZENS, THAT'S AN
ISSUE THE PRESIDENT HAS RAISED.
HE INITIATED A COMMISSION LAST
YEAR THROUGH AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
TO LOOK AT THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTION PROCESS.
WE HOPE THAT THIS IS JUST ONE
STEP IN THAT OVERALL EFFORT TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR ELECTIONS ARE
CLEAN AND FAIR AND INFLUENCED BY
AMERICANS FIRST AND FOREMOST.